I'm a thief air flow and I've been
commissioned to develop some CDF
documents to teach second year
undergraduates at the University of
Portsmouth the elements of algorithms on
graphs so for example minimum spanning
tree and maximum network flow it's been
a very successful project I'm going to
talk about it so yeah today I want to
talk about creating and deploying CDF
documents for undergraduate graph theory
teaching and this is a project between
myself and young Cokely bacova from
portsmouth university so i was very
happy to get there was a smart observe
fairly small as i thought application
jonker wanted she well she has large
classes around about seventy three
students took this part of the of the
module this year and she found that they
didn't really get on with the very well
the traditional mathematical way of
presenting algorithms on graphs so she
wanted to she didn't really know it no
matter and him anything about CDF or
wolfram technology but she's kind of
come across it and she thought maybe
this would be the good tool to help
their students help her students learn
so and what I'm going to do today is the
at the idea is that there's going to be
abstract descriptions of the algorithms
there's going to be some concrete
examples and also the students are going
to be able to generate random graphs
using using a CDF player and then use
these graphs to understand and there's
some feedback feedback mechanism I'll
show you shortly to understand how the
various algorithms works so because this
is a fairly small project it's not like
a big grant system i'm going to show you
i'm going to go into some detail about
some coding details and the design of
the system so there's a little bit of a
tutorial on CDF as well so apologies if
you know all this stuff when you youth
you dream about it but I'm going to go
into some detail okay
so right I hope to give her a bigger
report on the results of using the tool
but the exams only just been taken and
marked so I can give you some
preliminary results but we haven't got
anything definitive yet okay so I me
unka started off with some PDF files and
she thought this really isn't
state-of-the-art she knew there must be
a better way of doing it so the idea is
that the student can control the
properties of the generated graphs as
well so they can control the number of
vertices the number of edges and they
can start on simple graphs and then
progress to more complex examples so
these are work her words that she felt
this was a big step forward from the
traditional setting where students can
only use the examples produced by the
teacher and can only get help and
feedback from the teacher okay so i'm
going to show you what what the outcome
was this is we did three up three
algorithms each in its own CDF document
so the common ones that are taught at
this level of crew scale and prim and
this algorithm is for finding a minimal
spanning tree of a network i'm going to
show you crew Skiles the premises is a
similar kind of interface
so this as you can see there's there's
three tabs here teaching learning and
help help is really just help is not
help on the theory help is just help on
how to actually use the interface
because some of the students have never
seen CDF or wolfram technology before so
they're going to need a little bit of
help so what we did here was just have
tool tips and here I've got sort of
dummy controls if you just click click
on that it gives you a tooltip telling
you how to use the controls but they
don't otherwise actually do anything ok
so in teaching mode we just look at a
fixed example here so what we have here
is a graph and what it does is it
highlights the energy least weight and
then all you need to do now is just the
only thing you can do with this tab here
is just step forward so if you step
forward it says okay that was the node
of Lee sweat that was the edge of least
wait that was a three the next one
considered is a four and so forth so it
goes through choosing the edge of each
let each of least weight at each point
and then at the end the algorithm
terminates so the interesting thing
about then there were some challenges
the interesting thing about this
particular project was that she wasn't
really content with this traditional
standard graph facilities that you get
with a graph package she wanted to be
able to do things like move move the
edge labels around and later on we'll
see i created a later interface which
uses moving nodes as well so so that was
an essential feature of the project and
it was quite interesting because that
took quite a lot of coding to sort of
manage to manage that that side of
things was actually more difficult than
to code up the algorithms which you know
a quick look on wikipedia informed me
about how they worked but and it wasn't
long to code them but the most of the
time went
into the interface okay so the other the
other aspect is you can create your new
graph so you can adjust the number of
vertices here of course the number of
edges has to has to be greater than what
no more than one less than the number of
vertices because we want to use
connected graphs only and you can add
the students can adjust the weight and
clicking on you graph gives a new graph
for them to explore so this was again
this was something that the Yankee fell
pay they needed to have
so the other thing that that we tried to
do was to integrate the the theory that
the students see with the interface
itself so there was some some
information here about the theory which
I'm not sure how much the students read
we didn't test that but the idea was
that this should match as far as
possible the actual the look and feel of
the interface itself so the students
didn't have to translate too much from
one location to another so um so this is
a formal definition of a network many of
you will know this very easily others
may not be so familiar with it but what
I'm going to do is I'm going to show you
the next interface which is for
computing the maximum network flow so a
network is an ordinary graph with a
source and a sink and it's a flow is an
assignment to every arc such that it's
feasible in other words the the amount
of flow carried on an arc is less than
the capacity of the arc or equal to the
capacity and the flow is conserved in
other words for all internal vertices
the flow in must equal to flow out so
so here's an example of a flow quite
fitting on the screen there we are so
again a lot of time was went was spent
on deciding I'm not quite sure I I like
the eventual colors and style but this
is what the client wanted and this is
what we got so there was quite a lot of
fiddling around with thickness of
borders and so on which surprised me is
this was my first kind of project at
this kind surprised me quite how much
discussion and work there was involved
in just deciding on the look and feel of
things so anyway that's that's an
example and you can see that the red
ones are saturated they're already
carrying a maximum flow and the the key
points of the students to explain and it
took some I had to find look around for
some good examples was in this case the
highlighted and I let me show you in a
minute actually not got the right colors
to show you that okay
it's going to create a bit more screen
space here I was my idea anyway
oh I know why it's because I've got two
tabs here once still open
okay so um so the way this works is the
way the algorithm works and the way the
students had taught this is that at
every stage in the network either you've
got a maximum flow already or there's a
path through the network which augments
the flow so in this case is the very
first there's no flow through the
network you can see that all the nodes
coming into all the Ark's coming into
the terminal node have got zero flow so
the first number is the flow and the
second number is the capacity so this is
how it starts out and the system shows
you a flow of menteng path and the
student all the student has to do is to
say say what the maximum flow is so if I
open this tab here so the students is
prompted to enter the maximum flow and
it's gone off the rails now but it's say
if they enter to you check the flow
along the path it corrects it for them
it says no actually this you can put
more through yes sorry yes okay know why
that was one of the questions we asked
her and it was a teaching point
apparently no they don't use self loops
in their course I haven't actually
investigated what happens if you have a
self loop but it it's not it's possible
yes but we decided to leave those out
because it was a kind of you know
probably possibly confusing thing I mean
the self loop will just it doesn't
really do anything because it's just
going back is that it's not going to be
it's not going to change the actual the
structure so we left those out and also
because you can see everything is a
straight line and I've got an arc label
that you can move around it wouldn't
make much sense it would be more
difficult to code it as well so it was a
convenient design decision for me okay
yes so now it highlights highlights the
flow that's just been its highlights the
the sort of pumping of the the data
through the flow so actually the
original path has now been augmented and
the first arc is in red to show you that
that that's at maximum capacity so yes
sorry no no you weren't putting your
just stretching so I'm okay so if you
step through it through then it shows
you another flow of lamenting path and
this was the kind of only algorithmic
the interesting thing in the example
really which was that in some cases you
have to undo a flow and you can see that
the arc from A to E is carrying a flow
of 8 and yet on the flow augmenting path
the path goes from s to c 2 e and then
backwards to a and then forwards to be
and then down to t so it's kind of a
basic form of backtracking but we need
to undo the flow on the on the arc from
A to E in order to in order to to get
more flow through the network so that's
this is probably the trickiest thing for
the students to grasp and what I reckon
here looking at that is that the maximum
flow we can put through this flow
augmenting path is too so if I check
that yeah so then hitter it shows the
foot path with the updated flow and you
can see that they arc from A to E has
been reduced in the flow it's carrying
by 2 and that actually helps us to pump
more flow through a different route
okay so as I was saying I think the the
sort of challenge within a you know very
tight budget and small-time timeframe
was to develop a graph system which was
interactive and where you could move you
can move the nodes around and you could
also move the edges around and I think
it's quite interesting that you know we
made the design decision to to spend
more time doing that than to implement
more functionality it would have been
much faster I could it on a prototype I
think with the necessary function
functionality but then we wouldn't have
had these nice features of the interface
yes no I've had to know that's all coded
directly in dynamic in a dynamic module
it would be very nice to have this
facility but as far as I know it's not
in life yes yes yes yeah so I mean I'll
show you a little bit about how it works
later on okay so so as I say yeah I'll
say bit more about that later what we
had hoped to do when you actually go on
to the teaching mode and you can design
your own graph let's is a slightly
bigger one what we had hoped to do was
to have to edit this so I've got three
tabs here explore just allows you to go
through the explore the algorithm by
going through steps so here we did a
little bit more in terms of user user
interaction it can remember the choices
and it's not really going to be very
useful but the students can go back and
review their their choices whether they
were right or wrong and that's another
area in which we could extend prove and
extend the package later so okay so so
you can you can either just step step
through it because the system computes
the series of flow augmenting paths or
the students can actually try to go
through step by step and decide what the
maximum flow is as I said what we had
hoped to do was to include the ability
to actually define by
series of choices to define the flow of
mounting path and by by starting on a on
an edge and then adding edges till you
get to the from get to the target so I
mean and that would be quite feasible to
do it's just we run out of time and
budget to do that so I'm so that taught
me something and let me just show you
one other feature that I didn't mention
before that when we're on the teaching
mode for the maximal spanning tree the
idea here is that you can you've got a
menu on each edge on each edge label and
you can decide to accept it or reject it
in that case that was the wrong edge to
choose I should have chosen this one
here if I accept that it goes green and
so and in this case the student can go
backwards and forwards and edit their
choices and also I've added there a peek
thing which gives you the whole solution
and a hidden to step so all these things
obviously could be could be made more
sophisticated and the system could be
made them a lot more informative of the
students okay so i've got about just
over ten minutes left so one of the one
of the design criteria was that it each
thing has to be a monolithic there's
three things for prim for chris gayle
and Fernet workflow and each interface
has to be in his own CDF document and
I've chosen just to have a single single
thing in each one because I don't want
to have to try and Link variables from
one dynamic module to another so each
each thing is its own separate interface
in a single CDF document and so but each
document itself as you saw has to have
various components so I'm going to show
you a kind of fairly simple design this
is what this is what I'm trying to build
as a much simpler version of the of the
interface but as you can see it's got
some controls which are common to ever
thing so this control for I for the
variable I will affect the whole system
you don't really need what I've done
here I've just chosen to show a panel of
data just to show you how they are the
various variables are interacting and
changing so this I is common to every
mode here but if I choose the peach mode
I've got a separate control for peaches
number of peaches perhaps and which
which of course is remembered when you
step from one tab to another so you've
got independent controls and independent
displays for different sections of the
of the CDF which well I think it's it
proved to be the design that we needed
to use for this particular application
so just to show you how we've done it
for those of you who couldn't just do it
without thinking I'm sure that some of
you can so it relies on three things
it's a manipulate it relies on tab view
and slide view and also it relies on
controls so as you can see here we've
got the main there's one control which
is just a standard control in and
manipulate which controls the the main
variable I and then there's a there's
three other controls which are basically
it's a slide view so that's a number of
controls within a slide view which has
to be an item as far as I know and then
you can choose in this slide view which
slide you're looking at so depending on
which slide you've chosen the view will
change its change its value here it's
got value to so it's referring to the
peaches tab and then the actual control
only the control for the peaches tab
will show on the interface appearance
elements 29 means you don't want to see
the controls for the slides because
you've already got that control on the
tabs okay and of course you need view
needs to be dynamic so it's dynamically
updated when changes are made to the
interface
okay oh the only thing is i did find out
it needed to use i did a panel on the
manipulate and i set panel to be fourths
because i had a number of nested
controls and and display areas and what
I didn't want is have too much screen
clutter because every time you you nest
one you get an extra bit of white space
so I chose to use a panel to false which
gives you a kind of manipulate with no
with no borders and then just to wrap
the whole thing in a single panel I mean
these these seem sort of micro issues
but actually you know my client was
quite particular she'd say you know I
need to have his really compact and I
need to have all these features as well
so that was why why it was a challenge
for me in the time okay so the other
thing is as I was saying this doesn't
have a built the graph package doesn't
have bilking built-in functionality for
doing these kind of things so I built my
own own sort of custom holder for graphs
and i reused to some degree i'd actually
didn't use this very much in theory i
could reuse the graph package system so
this last clause here allows me to have
my own kind of graph within the graph
data type if you like and but that just
meant for this code all this code here
is it just strips out the my own custom
option edge flows because graph doesn't
know about this so i use this for
development purposes but not actually
for in the final implementation so that
yeah i had to learn how to do that and
the movable edge labels this was thanks
very much to a stack exchange kooba
showed me how he would I think it's he
would do this and so what you do is it's
just simply using locators within a
dynamic module this doesn't have doesn't
have manipulate in it but obviously the
eventual one does and then there's just
a code here which which uses the locator
which is a function and so that's the
second argument to dine
so as you move the locator it constrains
it to move along this particular line
here and also not to move any further so
it was relatively straightforward to
extend that you know to the kind of edge
levels i was using and then later on to
actually add movable vertices as well
but quite rightly i knew i wouldn't have
time to discuss that yes so let me show
you actually something i wanted to
explain any detail because i haven't got
too much too much time now yeah like I
said most most of this most of the
energy went into doing designing this
and I just want to show you how I laid
out the eventual code it because it's a
monolithic thing at because it was going
to be as free CDF I found that all the
definitions and all the variables had to
be located within one dynamic module and
that meant quite a large document
because there's a lot of different
variables and actually I ran into
trouble like even in editing and started
to get very slow to edit so I would love
to find a better workflow there where I
can move information in an out of
dynamic modules and initialization
sections because I spent a lot of time
developing with standalone definitions
but then when I actually had to package
it up they all had to get stuffed into a
single dynamic module so and I needed
some help from the Wolfram help team to
do that so what I've done here is I've
just shown you that um I've plugged in
some sort of dummy dummy symbols just so
this is a kind of form of documentation
you can see I've got a graph in there
but that's just pasted in there and that
the interface still works it's just in
this case it's just a fixed a fixed
thing and I can't actually move it
around so but the interesting thing here
I noticed is you've got to be a bit
careful you asked if they're dynamic if
I move this oh I can't hang on
she'll be able to move that I can't okay
well that's all right then I think it's
because yeah I could move that and now I
find if I go back to my code that point
is going to have moved I think okay well
anyway this work this actually was
something I discovered yesterday I
didn't really intend to demonstrate but
this is the kind of form of
self-modifying code I produced here that
when I actually evaluate it it actually
goes back and edits the code that I've
written so you've got to be a bit
careful with it I suppose that just
illustrates that that manipulate and
dynamic are very powerful things okay so
I don't have much time to talk about
algorithmics there are again there's
built-in algorithms for there's built-in
algorithms for computing the maximum
flow through a network they work in the
graph package but I because I wanted to
do it step by step and show the students
all the details of the algorithm it
wasn't possible just to use that
functionality so I wrote this thing i've
called it shy because it was a bit shy
and revealing its secrets to me because
this was just slightly tricky in terms
of coding it was the most interesting
algorithm thing it's all it's simply
doing is its finding all the paths
through a network from one start node to
a finish node so you know there's
nothing very very dramatic to that but I
needed to make sure that that it was it
was sound anyway so that's just a bit of
code that shows you how to do that I
won't go into details because I'm
running out of time
okay so i have time to report very
briefly on the results of the teaching
she had 73 students the course was the
course in mathematical foundations of
computing and functional programming
that wasn't exhibited here in this talk
and graph theory is just one component
so Yankee said the results are slightly
better they were better by up to five
percent forty percent okay well goes up
to 45 which is not great but the
feedback from the tutorial was good they
liked the chance to play with the
software she's not sure how much they
used it outside the tutorials so I did
promise to talk about deployment and
basically it was just a downloadable CDF
file because we couldn't integrate it
with Moodle and it just wasn't worth
their worth the trouble to do so I think
it would be nice if it were able we were
able to deliver it over the web but I
don't think this code will work with
their web map with the new online
mathematical tools or so we won't be
doing that okay yeah hopefully in future
years you'll use them and perhaps what
we'd really like is to get a teaching
grant to develop this further or some
kind of resources so that we could sort
of roll this out a bit more to more
students and hopefully they'll find it
useful I had a slide and which you can
see if you download the the talk later
on how we can improve this and extend
this and I think it does need
refactoring because it's a very
monolithic thing that'd be very good to
make it more modular okay thank you very
much